right well what we're going to talk
about is the way we're using stereo
graphics to try and deal with a medical
condition that affects around 4% of the
people in the world it's one of the most
common eye complaints that people have
and you'll know what that looks like
because you're seeing kids even if you
haven't been one yourself who are
wearing a patch over one eye and that's
the main way we have had for the last
hundred years to treat those children I
started getting interested in computer
games because I loved playing computer
games and then I wonder well how did
computer games work how can I make them
better how can I make really good games
so we've been looking at how we can use
games to treat something called
amblyopia we're showing on the left here
what would you do with the left-hand eye
when you're wearing these stereo glasses
and in the right hand channel we're
showing what you'd see with your right
eye and by mixing the two together by
flashing between the two you see one
image but one eye sees one side of it
and the other eye sees the other to
create our games what we have to do is
make one scene for the weak eye and one
scene for the strong I am Bo pre
involves you having one good eye one bad
I'm what we're trying to do on the right
here we've got the background the main
character and on the left here we have
the character in the background again
but we have targets that you're aiming
for so you're trying to catch these
stars now to get this to do this
actually goes again just what the
derry-o graphics card by using wants to
do so behind me is Peter Laval who's the
head programmer for our project and he
can tell you about the way in which
we've had to manipulate the technology
so it does the work we need to do for us
when you do 3d graphics you'll end up
with three dimensional data XY and z
coordinates that you twist around and
put into 3d space the final step does
something like a camera lens to put it
in a sort of a comb the far stuff gets
smaller than your stuff gets bigger
someone figured out this really clever
idea of making their computer sneak in
and at that last step pull everything
apart so that they could take existing
games and make them 3d make them like a
3d movie and then as they were writing
this software they said hey we'll also
enable the
squad buffering option from the from the
90s where you can draw different images
to different eyes
unity set up for for split-screen stuff
like this we draw the two images over
themselves and we draw them in a very
specific order and this lets us use an
existing off-the-shelf tool like unity
to just do the stereoscopic rendering
with different stuff and each eye that
you really wouldn't want to use normally
because it causes really horrible eye
strain yes yes yeah we're using the
beasts older or more mature direct3d 9
stuff and we're sending that to OpenGL
surfaces and then OpenGL supports the
quad buffering thing this all exists
because Hall had students and they knew
that their students could relatively
easily use unity 3d for their coursework
and they wanted the students to be able
to program their hulls VR cave yes they
have a VR cave built from also and video
projectors and Nvidia stuff so we knew
that their software solution to tricking
unity into doing stereo rendering would
work with the same equipment we were
trying to use and that meant we could
take a lot of grunt work out of this
project by just using unity and wrapping
it through this quad a fire we call it
because it adds quad buffering to an
existing technology existed
thing an existing engine fingers doing
is it took it to four screens rather
than two it's sort of a pun on the
concept of double buffering if you're
thinking of someone drawing a cartoon
they're going to draw a cartoon and then
show you the image they've drawn the
double buffering means that the computer
draws something you're not seeing and
then it shows you what it's drawn
for starting to draw the next thing and
flipping the few images back in place
sometimes they'll do triple buffering
and they'll have one caught one image
ready for the monitor to display another
one in the process of the monitor
displaying and then the computer working
on the third and quad buffering is sort
of a pun because you're adding a second
screen so it looks to the software to
the developer to the programmer to
someone like me it looks like you you're
drawing two images per frame and because
they both have this back off screen
buffer you're drawing to that's then
flipped with the front buffer it's one
two three four quad buffering when we
started I like any good programmer
thought I could do it all from scratch
that I'm still sure that I could have
but it would have been harder to
collaborate with other people on the
team the big sort of challenge has been
reducing the getting everything to just
sort of line up right so that it works
without touching without fixing without
oh you have to hit ctrl Q so that would
sort of be the big challenge would be
because this is supposed to go into
somebody's home and we they won't have a
keyboard and mouse and we assume they
have no technical expertise and it has
to just work and then we're doing this
weird little cocktail of sort of
software it ends up being slightly
frustrating most of what we do in
universities is really good stuff but
it's never going to go out there and
actually work in the real field it never
has to just never has to just work yeah
but we have the position where it has to
work it has to be something which is as
attractive as a commercial game as fun
as a commercial game and yet still do
the medical stuff that we need it to do
and so we've had a designer who's a pro
designer from a games company working
with us and we've got PTO's worked in a
games company we've got Mia's been
developing games for a very long time
and sold games before put games out
there and worked with games companies as
well so we're yeah we're beginning to
but get to the point where were we ready
to to roll out as a games company
ourselves and then he won't
any money so rather than indicate in the
movie this is indicating the research
group yes oh dear
it's now on Kickstarter so I've used the
demo to try and generate some height for
the game there's a ROM you can download
you can play using an emulator Windows
Mac and Linux even some handheld
consoles have some emulators see you can
put the ROM in there and play it on
there if you got something like an
overdrive card